i think what's interesting about the
metaverse
at least early on is it's likely to be
some mixture of social vr and and gaming
and in fact that's what you'll find to
some extent in this world that paul and
ed have created
the reason for kind of coming in having
a chat with you with you about this is
facebook kind of pivots to meta and the
metaverse you've been dealing with
virtual reality and mixed reality for
decades now is that right i mean why now
this interesting question i mean the
meta versus an idea as a kind of an
online mass social vr thing and that's
been around for a long long time in fact
before you really trumped me i was
reading neil stevenson's book snow crash
1992 which is where uh in this cyberpunk
novel that the term metaverse first
comes up um
and they've been several attempts to
kind of create meta verses over the
years second life in active worlds was a
kind of big commercial try to roll it
out
and i guess one of the questions that
underlies whether you can do this is
about just the infrastructure uh is the
world technically ready for it do people
have powerful enough computers and
devices are the networks fat enough and
you know i guess the facebook uh
microsoft and others are now banking on
the fact that we're pretty much there
and we can really roll this out into
many many people's homes so who's going
to be hosting this meta versus facebook
trying to just get the get the jump on
people i can't speak for what facebook's
business model might might or might not
be you'd have to ask them but i mean you
know i think it's interesting to think
about why
the different angles those bigger
companies are coming from and as you
know as a
i guess a social platform company that's
invested in vr headsets what six or
seven years ago now you know facebook
has been positioning themselves for a
bit to take the step you know as a
company that makes
uh computer games and platforms
microsoft also might be coming at it
from another angle is there a huge
amount of server side stuff happening to
make this work i mean it's being created
in unity i can tell that because it told
me when i
joined but
what's going on server side what's going
on client side can you talk us through
it the server side handles our
communication and
moving around so where you see everyone
else and also messaging through the
shout function whilst client side
handles all the looks and how everything
is portrayed just to keep things simpler
the server side is combining freeze
other technologies which is agora for
the video and audio that you're hearing
mirror networking which is
how we're moving the avatars around and
a service called pubnub which is for the
messaging that you'd see in shouting so
there are some technical challenges
uh which are quite interesting uh from
from a research perspective about how
you make this stuff scalable zoom calls
teams calls etc they don't scale
especially well
and they don't scale well for a few
different reasons so part of its
technical part is about bandwidth how
many video feeds can you put on the
screen and i
i'm part of it's social
how do you organize a conversation with
a hundred people when only one person
can talk at a time
and what we were interested here with
was how do you take those hundred person
teams calls
and make them
socially functional
right when you have a when you have a
hundred people in a real room
it's not the case that one person talks
at a time what happens is people
distribute across the room they spread
spatially into smaller conversations
people whisper in the corners they nudge
each other even if you're in a kind of
lecture environment there's still a
little bit of back channeling going on
but in a social environment that's even
more necessary for people to be able to
form small social groupings
and this platform is all about
spatializing those video calls being
able to go off into a corner
but it's actually a little bit more than
that because
first of all
we need to make
capable of handling
more than a thousand people right
imagine a big music festival so we've
been looking at small music vessels but
imagine a glastonbury where you've got
100 000 people there the problem is
everybody wants to go to the stage
everyone's going to want to go to where
the action is then you've got everybody
in the same server where the action is
so how do you handle that well our idea
was to allow people to create what we
call bubbles which is why this system is
called bubbles or their own private
instances of the world where only they
and the people they want to share a
video call with and the performers are
part of that world you're still aware of
everybody else everybody else appears as
certain little ghostly avatars
but you have this high fidelity
communication with just the small group
of people that are in your bubble
and that creates this really interesting
social question of
how do you create bubbles how should
they be organized is it you know you buy
some tickets and as a family group or a
friend group you're given a bubble or is
it
here is a social bubble for dog lovers
or a social bubble for people who are
specifically interested in drinking
guinness or whatever whatever social
groupings there might be
i think that's quite an interesting uh
research challenge for us is to think
about
how you would structure bubbles how you
get people into bubbles because it's
both technically necessary to make the
system scalable
but also socially necessary to make the
social situation scalable for me the
most interesting thing i think about it
is that emerges this kind of digital
world with real world social interaction
which is the kind of it's the best of
both really um so it allows you to
participate in social occasions
from the comfort of your own home
without losing the ability to connect
with people on a kind of very human
level in a really naturalistic way which
i really like
yeah i'm not i'd really like this idea
of kind of even just looking at the pose
of someone you can see if they're
looking at you or talking to someone
else or paying attention to something
else i mean
we're kind of using this a little bit
like a teams or a zoom call but it's
just so much better because i can kind
of go over here and talk to steve or i
can go and talk to paul or i can go back
to talk to ed so there are several core
activities here the most important one
because it's a festival is the main
stage just to show you how that works
i'm going to step onto the stage now i'm
now a performer and what's happening
here is you can all see me regardless of
what bubble you're in
we've increased the size of my avatar so
that i appear on stage as a large
onstage performer we've increased the
audio quality of my avatar so if i want
to play music to you um i
can well then come on let's have some
music i probably shouldn't
come on let's have some music
why not should really get steve doing
this he's much better at this kind of
thing
[Music]
i should really have tuned my guitar
before doing that never mind
anyway where's the applause button where
is this
um
media asynchronous media so when you
look at a lot of online festivals
um they're a mix of live performance and
pre-recorded performance and videos
um and so we wanted to showcase that in
here this is using a set of green screen
videos so i'll let you go up to the
video yourself because they're
locally played
[Music]
the second video format we wanted to
look at was 360 video because here we
are in a 3d world why not allow for 360
videos
we have these balls and the balls are
interesting because they're a way of
presenting 360 degree video
from the outside and what essentially
you do is you walk into one of the balls
as you walk in you'll find the video
starts to play and you can look around
and feel like you're
there
so you can view them from the sphere
outside or
go in
it's the last is a more kind of standard
video where we can walk up to a video
and it starts playing
one of the companies we're in
conversation with at the moment is a
circus to look at
how you might use volumetric video
3d video capture where you can actually
look all the way around the video for
yet another kind of form of
um
embodied content in here when you go to
a festival it's not just music
right there's more there
there are sideshows there are activities
and
the busy castle and the ferris wheel
are there to provide that
they're just silly examples
but they're very easy to do
[Music]
so the system already allows you to jump
but if you stand in the bouncy castle
you can jump a bit higher
it's like a bouncy castle except no kids
have been sick on it
[Music]
i think one of the key things
about this whole thing is it goes beyond
being a zoom meeting or uh you know a
team's meeting is it's placeful
and you know one of the things we really
wanted to create was the festival as a
sense of a place that you go to perhaps
more than
just watching a performance you know all
of the other things that you can wander
around and spend your time doing
and i think that um you mentioned
playful we happen to be in um willitton
park by the looks of it that's bulletin
hall behind you which is
some viewers may recognize as it was
wayne manor in one of the batman films
but that's in nottingham so that's where
we are at the moment
um
but
one thing that's quite important for all
this sort of stuff is is that idea of
the state of the place and does it
change if i change something will you
see that change
so that is our kind of next goal
um we have the we have the technology as
they say um
behind this so we we know
we know how to do it we haven't
implemented it for this particular
version
um
but
one challenge there is how you make that
interact with the bubbles system the
idea of we're in separate bubbles so
how do we sync
the the world itself
so you can sync objects with this idea
that
in a specific bubble you should sync
the videos the audio the balls in the
coconut shy the gondolas and the ferris
wheel
any kind of physical objects should get
synced
correctly for a specific bubble but they
don't need to be synced for a separate
bubble the question you might reasonably
ask yourself is what happens if you
switch bubbles
whose world do you get right if i've got
a ball from the coconut shroud rolling
across the floor and i join your bubble
should i join it
where there's no ball rolling over the
coconut shower should i bring my rolling
ball with me and this is interesting
questions about negotiation about
ownership
of bubbles and that kind of ties right
back into
metaverse and commercial ownership of
the metaverse right so if i own this
theme park
right
then
should it be my version of the theme
park that everybody gets or do they get
to spawn off their own version of my
theme park if i build a house in here
imagine i'm playing minecraft and i've
got to serve if i build a house in the
server and somebody hides off a version
of that server
who owns it at that point
and those are real challenges we've seen
this before in second life and things
like this from a computer scientist you
know kind of point of view you know pull
something talk about something really
interesting when do you want the world
state synchronized and when you want it
asynchronous and in this kind of
environment where it's kind of crowded
with potentially lots of strangers but
you're also in it with some people that
you're sharing it with a small group of
friends or family you sort of want both
if i go up to the coconut shy i don't
want to have to wait for a thousand
people to finish with it before i have
my go on the other hand if i go up there
with you as my mate we want to play
together and paul's notion of bubbles
that you can get into a little bubble
with people and that means you can share
audio and video with them and you can
share world state i think it's really
nice for that as long as my high school
follows me steve i don't really mind
another kind of tie back to the
metaverse the idea of there being
virtual real estate that exists when we
start playing with this notion of
bubbles i can sell the same house 50
times to different people all of whom
are having that same address in the same
location and just happen to add this
bubble to that address
and suddenly you get reusable real
estate what that will do to those people
who want to sell digital real estate is
another question entirely but uh i think
it's an interesting it's an interesting
question i would move between
we originally called the system
dimensions this idea that you would have
several dimensions of the same
environment
it sounds like all you need to do is
add the word blockchain to that and
you've got an ipo ready to go
have you
used this for meetings and things i mean
can talk to me about that could this be
something some people you know use or
jump into so we used it for meetings in
its own development
um which was an interesting activity
because
it was it was obviously building as we
went along so we were finding errors as
we went along and finding quirks as we
were went along and working out how much
audio attenuation was appropriate and
that's when you reduce the volume if you
move away from people right absolutely
um so yeah we used it we used it for
its own meetings we also had our
christmas party in it which was quite
fun um i dressed the world up for that
so we put snow on the ground i replaced
the trees with christmas trees we made a
snowball fight mechanic
um
and that's interesting end of itself
because so it pulled the pulled the
mechanics out of the the coconut shy but
allowed to throw the balls at each other
and score a point and then we put up a
leaderboard uh in in one corner of the
room
or one part of the space
um
and it created this extra little layer
of things to do in the space specific
interaction things to do and a snowball
fight's a funny thing because
it isn't always between friends you know
if you get a snowball fight in a village
people will just join in even with
strangers um and i thought that was an
interesting thing to play with this
notion of a
a
competitive ish but not too competitive
game that could just be snuck in
to the environment so that if the
conversation died down you can just lob
a snowball at somebody um which i mean
i've been in lots of academic
conferences where occasionally i would
like to just love a snowball um i think
i was talking about this morning
actually that the the first five minutes
of a zoom meeting or a team's meeting
when everybody's waiting for people to
arrive
there's a rather awkward silence and i
like the idea of having a ferris wheel
or a coconut shy or a snowball fight
just to fill that gap yeah yeah perhaps
there just needs to be an alarm to bring
you back because of course you won't
hear people starting to speak when
you're at the other side of the
i mean
yeah obviously i wouldn't want to
contribute to anything that blurs the
definition between a party in a meeting
that would be a i think a dangerous
thing i think as long as you bring your
own booze it's absolutely fine people
sort of tend to agree in the visions of
the metaverse that it's persistent and
you know and that means kind of several
things it means uh it's kind of always
there when you want it but it also means
that you can sort of change it and it
stays changed and it possibly means that
you can own it too and that's been the
business model of you know things like
second life in the past by real estate
in the meta person i think it was very
much the idea in the book
and then paul's idea of bubbles plays
with that in a crazy way because now you
can also have parallel versions of the
universe that are somehow connected and
now question of who owns what becomes
much more interestingly complicated but
i mean you know just to kind of play
devil's advocate people were selling an
acre on the moon you know 20 30 years
ago i've got an acre on the moon i'm
hoping one day i'll get to visit it i
mean um this then probably comes down to
who owns what server right and and you
know feel like there's not going to be
the money to be made for the mark
zuckerbergs in this world if
everything's open source i don't know
what do you think there's a slightly
more altruistic goal are
the mechanics behind what we're doing
with this software is to build a
platform on which you can overlay this
communications medium on lots of
existing worlds or worlds that you
create so
anybody that can build a world in unity
ultimately we'll be able to import that
world into this space
now that is definitely at odds with the
notion of
a platform that would like everybody to
use the same platform and ideally buy
bits of it
however we're still dependent on
third-party technology providers so ed
mentioned earlier on that we use agora
as our back-end video conferencing
system now they have hundreds of servers
they have
you know
significant resource and bandwidth for
shipping video around and because they
have that they're going to do it better
than we could have done it
and
we are at that point kind of beholden to
their
servers so there's now a cost associated
with running this system
which means that we can't simply open
source it and say hey everybody go do
your own thing because there is actually
a bandwidth cost there is a network cost
and regardless of whether we ran it
ourselves there would be a network and a
bandwidth cost so these things can't be
entirely free which means there needs to
be some degree of commercialization
whether that is through a large company
like meta facebook
microsoft whomever making them available
for
you know advertising or subscription or
whatever or whether that's through us
saying here you can have this thing but
you will have to pay a subscription to a
goer to be able to use it
or whether it is us saying okay here's
this thing
and here's a plug-in by which you can
plug
zoom or skype or whatever into it and
then separate all those feeds there's
lots of different ways we might approach
the problem
yeah i would say you know i'd hope at
the very least that you know the
protocols for the metaverse will be
like with the web uh support
interoperability and you know there's
been lots of attempts to do that in the
past the
virtual reality markup language vrml
onwards have been attempts for people to
define standards for this so you'd hope
at that level things will inter-operate
fingers crossed kind of thank all of you
for joining us today and uh it's been
great and i might go off and have a go
on the ferris wheel
yeah enjoy it
thanks very much sean bye
so let's look at b we probably don't
want to go that way so this is going to
be a smaller or bigger wire depending on
if you're a mathematician or a computer
graphics person so we're going to go
this direction now we're looking at e
and the problem and i think mike's going
to demonstrate this in a second
is that
log4j is like milk it's like water it's
everywhere